pick something aim at it as you move
toward it you'll get wiser then maybe
your aim will change that's okay but at
least it'll change in an informed way
it's like discipline yourself in one
dimension see what happens well that's
exciting and I think that's something
that's open for everyone and I think you
can find yourself in situation that's so
dire that there's no escape from it but
that doesn't matter because the best we
have might not always work but it's
still the best we have and the fact that
it might not work doesn't mean we should
throw it away it's still the best we
have I mean everyone dies and so we fail
in some sense the fact that the symphony
ends doesn't mean that it wasn't worth
listening to need motivation watch this
top 10 with believe Nation hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that Push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best Jordan Peterson and my take
on his top 10 was a success enjoy
rule number two look where it's
important you look where you think it's
important to look
so I'll say that again you look where
you think it's important to look and
that means that well in a hierarchy of
importance is no different than a
hierarchy of value they're the same
thing a hierarchy of priority is the
same as a hierarchy of value and a
hierarchy of priority and a hierarchy
value and an ethic are all the same
thing right because you're going to look
at what you believe to be of cardinal
importance
otherwise you look well if you're
talking to someone and you look at their
feet
that's not going to be going very well
right first of all they're not going to
be very impressed with you because they
actually want you to look at their eyes
and that's because we communicate value
with our eyes and we do that directly
our eyes have even involved to do that
our eyes have whites around the iris so
that you can see where people Point them
because it's that important to know what
people think is important we see the
world through a structure of value
and I think that a huge part of that
structure of value is actually derived
from the entire set of texts entire set
of texts and they're into relationship
that have the biblical Corpus at their
base and so it seems to me that you I
think you can make a pretty damn strong
case
maybe on scientific grounds that you
can't see the world except through the
lens of the Bible
like literally you actually can't see it
now if it's not the Bible it might be
some other Corpus of texts but it might
be it isn't
and if it was well is it going to be a
corpus of text that we share because if
it isn't then we can't share our
perceptions and our values and if we
can't share those then we fight those
are the options right we either
stabilize our hierarchies of value in
some way that we agree upon mutually or
we fight that's or we're unbelievably
chaotic and confused and that'll just
produce fighting in any case and so
we have this structure of texts built
from the bottom up it's predicated on
the biblical narratives
and the texts exist in relationship to
those underlying narratives and derive a
fair bit of their meaning from the
meaning of the underlying narratives and
and vice versa you know
um
and so then the biblical is it possible
that biblical truth is the sort of truth
that is the precondition for truth
right because you think well it's
religious people make the claim people
of the Bible make the claim the Bible is
true well there's all sorts of different
kinds of truth that's that's an
interesting claim but it's not very
elaborated it's it's insufficient
um and you know often what happens to
Christians when they debate skilled
atheists like Richard Dawkins as they
treat the Bible like it's a scientific
theory and Dawkins just mops the floor
with them because it's actually not a
scientific theory compared to scientific
theories and so as soon as you go there
well it's like a scientific theory it's
like no it's not it's not and so does
that mean it's not true well it means
that if the only thing you think is true
is a scientific theory
but
I don't think that you can practice
science except within an ethical
framework that's not in itself science
and so it's possible that there is a
deeper truth than the scientific truth
which is the ethic that has to be their
a priority before you can even begin to
do science rule number three encourage
reading we should make much more of an
effort to ensure that kids are
unbelievably proficient readers and a
lot of that is going to involve early
automatization of letter and phoneme and
syllable and word recognition so because
what happens is
when you teach a child to read first of
all you teach them the alphabet and the
sounds and we have an alphabetic
language thank God because it makes
things much simpler and so you teach
them the letters and then the two letter
combinations and then the three letter
combinations then they can sound out
syllables and then they get words but it
isn't until you can read phrases
automatically at a glance that you can
read for content and pleasure
and so a lot of kids get stuck
especially if they don't come from
particularly literate homes where where
all of this is sort of taught you know
maybe starting at
you know 12 months when they're first
dragging a book around and and becoming
familiar with the book as an object
right before they even learn to read
you got to get kids through that
automatization phase and that requires
intense Mass practice and that's not
that intrinsically interesting right but
if you can get them to the point where
they can read for Content well then it
starts to become interesting just as
interesting let's say as going to a
movie or perhaps playing a video game
and so that has to be made an absolute
priority and and the far if the
faculties of Education were doing their
job they would have produced technology
to solve that problem for virtually
every child because it is only a matter
of practice smarter kids will learn
faster but with enough practice pretty
much everybody is going to get there
so and then there's the marketing issue
it's like well why should you read well
do you want to be stupid
you want to be stupid what happens when
you're stupid you walk into walls
because you don't see them and if
someone comes along who's more educated
than you more literate and canier
they'll just
you'll lose man you'll lose and you'll
lose too because you can't think
properly so you won't aim at the right
things and you won't be informed by the
great individuals of the past and you
need that we're historical creatures
this isn't optional
so part of it has to be
marketing for lack of a better word it's
not really that it's an explanation why
be literate
because it makes you
it helps you become who you could be
helps you move out into the world and
have your Great Adventure
and to bring people along God only knows
what you can do if you've got your words
lined up properly
and young men would listen to that if
someone who knew what they were talking
about was telling them that
as you found out rule number four be the
right person if you want an answer to
the first question
which is how do I find the person who's
right for me you actually start by
asking the second question which is what
can I bring to the table for someone
else and if you're really good at
bringing something to the table for
someone else hey man people might be
lining up to be your partner and if
they're not then you might think well
maybe I'm just not bringing the right
thing to the table
and that's worth thinking especially if
you're desperate you're lost and you're
alone it's like hmm maybe I got this
wrong and I you know I usually sort of
top that with a suggestion that even if
you did find the person who was perfect
for you and they're that perfect what
makes you think they wouldn't take one
look at you and run screaming away and
they likely would if they were that
perfect because you know really are you
that much of a catch
and if you think you are you know that
might be part of the problem
um
so so look so that's one right intimate
relationship so I would say to you at
the crossroads
develop a vision for your relationship
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five maintain moral
orientation how do you bear
the suffering that is at the Crux of
life
without becoming tempted and embittered
that's really really difficult now you
know someone might point out go ahead
and be bitter see where that gets you
and if you have any sense and generally
people have at least some they know that
being sick and bitter is worse than just
being sick and that being right it's
worse but it's very hard temptation to
avoid sometimes you want to be bitter
just out of spite in some sense because
things are so terrible all you've got
left is your willingness to shake your
fist you know and say well you know
really is this like this many poisonous
snakes really that's like maybe I could
have learned with just one or two not a
hundred
so but we're stuck we're all stuck with
that and I think we're stuck with it at
every level of our life in some sense is
how do we maintain a high order moral
orientation in spite of suffering and
malevolence rule number six have a clear
perception of reality I first started to
understand that
what we perceive in some real sense
isn't exactly material reality and
partly that's because that's actually
impossible
and I mean that technically and that's
something we could go into in great
depth because that realization paralyzed
a number of fields it really started to
come to the Forefront in many fields and
about in the early 1960s especially in
AI when the AI type started to try to
make machines that could see the world
in some sense like we do and then act in
the world and what they instantly
realized was that oh
there isn't just something there that we
see this is way harder than we ever
possibly imagined in fact it's so hard
that it looks like it might be
impossible in some sense so how the hell
do we do it and like we still don't have
robots that can move around the world
like we do you know endless Generations
I'm not I'm not maybe it's improved the
last time I looked at this great detail
we didn't have robots that could fold
laundry very efficiently either so yeah
well a lot of these so-called simple
things like seeing well it's half your
brain it takes you half your brain to
see and most animals like we see way
better than almost all animals say
Eagles Raptors really because bald
eagles in my back yeah they can see they
they their eyes are the same size as
yours and they have two phobia spots
Eagles uh Falcons they're the animals
that can see better than us but other
than that
it's us and it's half our brain just to
see well so why well you're a physicist
you understand that reality is composed
of levels of being right from the
subatomic up to the cosmic it's like
well first of all how do you specify the
proper level of analysis
well one of the things that's quite
interesting psychologically is that we
have short words
are generally used to describe things
that manifest themselves to us at our
level of analysis cat we see a cat we
don't see a species we don't see Cats
sub parts we see this cat well why well
that's that's the level that's most
biologically relevant to us given our
embodiment that's an evolutionary answer
and so we see what we see first of all
what we see a lot of is memory but we
see something that's overlaid on the
world we actually see the overlay and
hopefully it reflects what's underneath
and generally it does and it's a hell of
a shock to us when when we make a
perceptual error
but I see I and then I started to learn
especially from Reading Jeffrey gray
that we we also see the world within a
motivated frame
and he was influenced by Norbert weiner
who was one of the world's first
cybernetic scientists essentially a
great influence on AEI yeah and and gray
never talked about narrative but the
frame that he described that we see and
in animals as well basically has a point
a and a point B so we're always moving
towards a goal if we're mobile animals
and I thought Oh Well the description of
the movement from point A to point B
that's the simplest unit of meaning
that's a story
and then I learned that a better story
is a story about how stories transform
and so those are actually perceptual
frames of reference that transform and
then I understood that
if you don't have respect for the
transformation process above all else
then you can't transform your perceptual
frames when necessary and then you can't
adapt to error and that destroys you and
so that's that's all part of that rule
number seven organize around your goals
when you organize your perceptions
around a goal
that provides a container for your
negative emotions so if I want to walk
across the stage because I think that
getting to the other side is preferable
to being here so that's a hierarchy of
value that place is better than this
place
then when I observe myself undertaking
the actions that will get me to that
place that's comforting and provide
security because it shows that the
structure that I'm using to organize my
perceptions and to reduce the world to a
manageable
to manageability
is sufficiently accurate so that I can
implement it
and so we seem to inhabit those
structures all the time whenever we're
looking at the world whenever we're
interacting we specify a goal and so
that's an ethical Enterprise and we
organize our emotions within the
specification of that goal and then we
produce hierarchies of goals so you know
you go to you
you sit down in front of your computer
so you can write a paper and you write a
paper so that you can finish an essay
and you finish an essay so that you can
get a grade in a class and get a grade
in class so that you can graduate with a
degree and you do that so that you can
get a job and you do that so that you
can be what a good husband a good wife a
good citizen and you do that so you can
be a good person
there's a hierarchy of ethic that
permeates the entire Enterprise right
from the microcosm up to the macrocosm
and I think that's something like the
whole landscape of religious value with
the
outermost container so be a good person
let's say that's the
ultimate aim of the religious Enterprise
that's something like the imitation of
Christ in the most fundamental sense and
all the things that you do within that
are a reflection of that or you're
confused and chaotic and if everyone's
doing that at the same time then you
have a society that's integrated and
aiming up and capable of telling the
truth something like that does that seem
reasonable and so so what's the
proposition here well I think when we
describe these Frameworks of perception
the name we give to the description of a
framework of perception is a story
and I think the reason that we like
stories so much is because we need
to establish Frameworks of perception in
order to operate in the world and to
allow ourselves to
be integrated peacefully with other
people
and so we're extraordinarily interested
in anything that has a narrative basis
and the reason we're interested in that
is because we're trying to build within
ourselves and collectively the structure
that enables us to perceive the world
without undue confusion and chaos and in
a manner that provides some value to us
and some sustainability that's the goal
overall
and
that seems to me to be the goal of the
entire religious Enterprise and so
is it possible that
well I guess that's as that's the claim
I thought I'd
elaborate out a little bit today is that
the Bible is true
in a very strange way
it's true in that
it provides the basis for
truth itself
and so it's like a meta truth right
without it there without it there
couldn't even be the possibility of
Truth
and so maybe that's the most true thing
the most true thing isn't some truth per
se it's
that which provides the precondition for
all judgments of Truth
and it seems to me that
I can't see any holes in that argument
and I can't see any holes in it from a
scientific perspective either because I
think we do know well enough now as
scientists that the problem of deriving
ethical direction from the collection of
facts is an intractable problem there's
too many facts there's an infinite
number of facts they do not provide an
unairing guide for Action they can't
there's too many of them they have to be
prioritized
and as soon as they are prioritized well
then you're in the ethical domain and
then that begs the question what's the
valid ethical domain and the postmodern
answer is well there isn't one it's all
the expression of domination and power
and I think that's nonsense I I don't
think that's a tenable solution I think
that
we stumbled onto the proper answer in
some sense in our religious Enterprise
which is that we aim at what's highest
or or we don't
we aim at what's highest jointly or
we're divided we aim at what's highest
and that's gives meaning to all the
things we do that are subordinate parts
of that we aim at what's highest and
that's what collects us and gives us
structure all of that you know singly
and jointly
and that's all what we've been trying to
communicate
all these centuries as we've been trying
to communicate the whole religious
Corpus generation after generation and
to sort this out and to straighten it
out and to try to understand it
and uh
I think that's where we're at now you
know rule number eight accept suffering
if you're looking for certainty
the reality of suffering is certain
I mean
what do you accept as evidence Above All
Else
that's a good question that's a hard
question but I would say pain is up
there
it's very difficult not to believe in
the reality of your own pain
it's somewhat easier not to believe in
the reality of other people's pain
that's not so easy either you know but
it's your pain seems to be
undeniably real
and so
it does beg a question which is you know
if pain is undeniably real is that which
overcomes pain even more real
and I think that's in some sense that's
the idea that lurks behind the idea of
the Resurrection rule number nine remain
Noble when you see people who are Noble
in spite of their suffering it is
ennobling it is uplifting right like
really it is and
um and it it's been striking to me too
people want to be encouraged in that
direction I mean part of the reason that
my lectures I would say have been
successful to the degree that they have
been is because people find them
encouraging and that actually seems to
work like it seems to be positive
because it is good news well it seems to
be I mean it isn't necessarily the case
that that would be the case you know
because it could have been that I would
have said encouraging things to people
there's more to you than meets the eye
and you're capable of more than you're
demanding of yourself and you know if
you took on your responsibility and face
the things that you're trying to avoid
that your life would be richer and
better and for you and for everyone
around you and the result of that could
have been that thousands of people would
come to me and say you know I gave that
a pretty good shot and it your advice is
really awful and everything is well
seriously like I took on that
responsibility it just bloody crushed me
and I'm way worse off than I was before
and everything's gone to hell around me
and like thanks a lot buddy and that and
that it's not like that's a completely
incomprehensible possibility but that
doesn't seem to be what happens is what
generally happens is that young people
in particular but not only come to me
and say look I've been trying to take on
more responsibility and to face the
things I've been avoiding and everything
is way better it's like okay well isn't
that something to be onto something well
then you ask yourself well what's the
limit of that because that's the
religious question fundamentally is well
if you took on all the responsibility
you couldn't take on
and you faced everything that you needed
to face
what would you be like who would you be
and how would the world transform around
you and well if if the partial answer is
well if I do that a little bit things
get a fair bit better then the next
question might be well
what if you did that completely
and I don't think that's possible in
some sense right it's like you know
Perfection is a horizon that always
recedes but it isn't obvious to me
what the upper limit of that is and
certainly we do see people I mean Saints
right it's a Francis of assessment you
kind of push the limit and they
miraculous things happen around them and
maybe in the literal sense and if not in
the literal sense close enough you know
for all intents and purposes and so
that's heartening I mean I
tear myself apart about this in many
ways because I think
perhaps it's possible to take on too
much responsibility and to crush
yourself as a consequence maybe that's a
sin of Pride who knows it's certainly
possible but my experience so far has
been that
when you see people bear their suffering
nobly
there's nothing in that but good
not something and then when you see
people take on more responsibility and
decide that they're going to aim up and
and
confront their suffering honestly and
forthrightly that their lives get better
and the lives of people around them get
better too
and so it's that's very strange as well
because it also means that the pathway
to less suffering
is through suffering
right and that's kind of that would be
hopeful if the world was constituted
that way it's like well they're
suffering how do you make it worse run
away
how do you make it better confront it
yeah but it's suffering it's like yeah
but it's there there it is it's right
there it's a precondition for existence
or something like that and it's like you
have something important to do as well
and you confront it and that's the
pathway to transcending it and Rule
Number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is encourage
greatness I was watching this movie King
Arthur by Guy Ritchie and when when the
new king young King Arthur takes his
sword he has flashbacks to his evil
Uncle killing his father and it just
it's so terrible that he can't hold on
to the sword
and I thought well what's Richie doing
there it's well that's the case for all
of us isn't it because when we look into
the past and we see our evil uncles it's
just a complete bloody catastrophic Mass
isn't it slavery and genocide and War
and oppression and like and that's on
all of us isn't it and it's always
lurking there in the background and so
is that male power well yes in some ways
I mean if you don't give a man a sword
he can't use a sword right so not giving
him a sword is one way of making sure
he's peaceful but it's not the it's not
the optimal way and besides if you
[ __ ] men they become far more
dangerous
they've become dangerous in an UNT
terrible underground fashion of course
the same is exactly true with you
[ __ ] women but we're speaking
particularly of boys because I suppose
there's an education crisis among boys
and young men
well you want to encourage that power
because it's actually a tremendous Force
for good if it's brought under control
and so but that's a hard thing to get
right and it also requires a lot of
trust and work on the part of women
because they want to it's like Beauty
and the Beast right because beauty
entices that Beast who's a real who's
real but uncivilized and dangerous she
sort of entices him into becoming fully
developed and that's what a woman has to
do when she you know has that
work project that she marries or has a
long-term relationship with
but
it's much better to encourage with with
faith and trust
and this is another thing you can do in
your own household this is so useful man
if you get good at doing this your life
will get so much better you can't
believe it is watch the people around
you
and whenever they do anything that you
would like to see repeated on a regular
basis
tell them exactly what they did in
detail with you know be positive about
it obviously and and just indicate that
you noticed and because I saw this when
I was grading student essays you know
and so I taught this seminar for a long
time and I was trying to teach kids how
to write they were in their fourth year
of University in the honors psych
program you'd think they'd bloody well
already know how to write but they
didn't and so
I'd have them write a four-page essay on
a given topic and then they had to
rewrite that to a six page essay and
then they had to rewrite that to an age
eight page essay and the first essay I
graded I was only five percent of their
grade and I told them I'm going to cut
you into ribbons but it doesn't matter
because it's you know five percent of
your grade and so they could tolerate
that and generally by the third essay
they had written the best thing they'd
ever written in their life and they
learned so fast it was unbelievable but
one of the things I noticed was that
they did a little testing with the first
essay they'd hand in something was just
like God formulaic boring they weren't
in it at all you know there was nothing
of the person in there there was no
thought there was just the kind of
psychobabble that they'd learned
especially if they were in faculties of
education and and it was dry and dull
and and everything about it was wrong
and so those are hard to grade right
what's wrong with my essay well the
words aren't right the phrases they're
not so good they're not organized well
into sentences the sentences aren't
sequenced well in the paragraphs the
Peregrine's paragraphs don't make a
coherent argument and the entire thing
is empty but other than that no problem
it was often easier just to rewrite
those essays than to grade them no so in
any case though one of the things I did
learn was that even in an essay like
that there is usually like one sentence
or two sentences buried on like page
three that was an actual thought
and reasonably clearly stated and
somewhat gripping you know it was like
the person popped out from all the
background rubbish and said
well what what about this hey and if you
saw that and checked it and said hey you
hit the mark right there the next essay
would be like two-thirds that and that
was really fun to see and then maybe by
the third essay maybe it was all like
that and then they were really thrilled
it's like wow I wrote this you know and
sort of the culmination well it was a
fourth year seminar it was the
culmination of their their career as a
psychology undergraduate so that was
great fun but you can do that in your
own household if if if
if the envious part of you isn't jealous
of the revelation of the goodness of the
person when I was 25 or so I probably
weighed about 138 pounds I smoked like a
pack of cigarettes a day I drank
a tremendous amount of alcohol I was
from Northern Alberta this rough little
town up in Northern Alberta called
Fairview and you know there were long
Winters there and my friends were heavy
Drinkers and most of them dropped out of
school by the time they were 15 or 16
went off to work on the oil rigs and you
know it was a rough town and we drank a
lot I started when I was 14 and you know
um
and so I was I had a lot of bad habits
let's say and uh things that were and I
wasn't in great shape physically and I
was also still intellectually obsessed
by as I am now and uh
so that would have been that would have
been in 85 but when I but I decided
around that about 85 84 something like
that maybe a little earlier that I was
really going to try to get my act
together and uh
so I started doing that I you know I
first of all I I quit smoking oh that
took a long time because I eventually
had to quit drinking too in order to
quit smoking and I started working out
starting playing sports which I'd never
done I had a fine time when I was a kid
and but uh I needed really to get
disciplined and I had to do it because
I was working on these hard problems
that you know that I've been discussing
with all of you and I've been working on
them really you know obsessively since I
was probably about 18 maybe even earlier
than that and got to the point around 25
when I was in graduate school trying to
get my phds doing all my research like I
published 15 papers by the time I
graduated with my PhD which was by I
think by a fairly large measure the most
papers that any graduate student at that
time had ever published at McGill I
think that's right might have been twice
as many or maybe twice as many maybe
even three times as many and at the same
time I wrote maps of meaning which was a
terrible terrible terribly difficult
thing to do because I was writing about
three hours a day doing that and I
couldn't do all that and continue with
my misbehavior you know my sort of my
what what would you say my my my
hedonistic
my hedonistic
my massive hedonistic consumption of
alcohol and all of that I just couldn't
keep it up and also work seriously on
the issues that were at hand so you know
I had to stop that's a sacrifice I had
to stop
messing about and straight myself out on
that point of understanding my
inadequacies or someone's inadequacies I
really believe that that it's really
difficult to undergo self-development if
you don't have self-awareness and I was
I was really trying to understand from
your writings how someone is to build
their self-awareness it's almost like
the unknown unknown if you don't have it
how do you build the thing I know a good
exercise for that
It's Like a Prayer in some sense in fact
I would say it's proper prayer if you
want to know something about yourself
sit on your bed one night and say to
yourself you got to mean this like you
got to be desperate this is no game this
it's like
my life is not everything I wanted to be
and perhaps it's not everything that I
need it to be and by need I mean my life
is so unbearable that
the suffering that's attended upon that
is make me nihilistic cynical bitter
resentful homicidal genocidal unable to
have a good relationship Pro prone to
punish people for their virtues because
of my jealousy uh driving the proclivity
to see evil everywhere except within my
own Heart Like These are problems man
and you ask yourself you sit on the bed
and say okay man I'm ready to
learn something like what what's one
thing I'm doing wrong that I know I'm
doing wrong that I could fix that I
would fix it's like you meditate on that
you'll get an answer and it won't be one
you want but it'll be the necessary one
you know and it's often
something that will point you to small
things
so Carl Jung said people in the modern
world don't see God because they don't
look low enough
and so imagine you're in your messy
bedroom
you know and you're sitting on the edge
of the bed trying to have an honest
dialogue with yourself and the little
voice says
you know it's pretty disgusting in here
and you think well I'm way above Such
trivial niceties as organizing my room
it's like
well that's Pride that's arrogance
if you're above
organizing what's actually yours how in
the world are you ever going to organize
anything else and so you get on your
knees and you think
well it's time to you know
take a brush to the toilet
and maybe that's where you start
and so and that works like that works
you start making those micro
improvements like real micro
improvements real on the ground actual
micro improvements to things you know
that are wrong you'll improve
unbelievably rapidly you have to make a
decision in your life and this is
this is a decision and I would say that
it's a voluntary element of Faith
because it isn't exactly evidence based
it's more like something you decide
before you even look at the evidence
it's more like you decide to stake your
life on this like you know if you decide
to get married to someone you don't
really do it on the basis of the
evidence that you're going to have a
happy life because you don't have that
evidence you do it you decide that
you're going to make a happy life with
this person and that it's worth the risk
so you you get married as an expression
of faith
okay and and so Faith doesn't mean
believing things that no one with any
sense would believe Faith sometimes
means putting a stake in the sand and
saying here's where I stand
in some sense regardless and you do that
when you get married you do that maybe
when you you know pledge allegiance to a
friend you have a best friend and you
want to maintain that friendship as long
as you possibly can it's it's it's a
decision of Faith
um maybe you do that when you decide a
career when you go to university because
you could have done something else right
but you chose that so that's where you
put your faith
um and like I said that doesn't mean
believing what no reasonable person
would believe okay so back to God is
love well I'm going to talk about being
first instead of God
um and being is the totality of
experience that we're going to Define
that it that way for the purposes of
this discussion
being is what there is instead of
nothing and you experience that as a
conscious creature being is what you
experience as a conscious creature it
includes all your emotions all your
motivations all your subjective
experience as well as everything that's
objective Okay so
it seems to me that all things
considered
it's a useful
move of Faith to act as if you love
being and if you love something then you
want the best in it to flourish and so
maybe you decide deep in your soul that
it would be better for you to act
towards an end that makes everything
that's good better that that's the best
way to live to make everything that's
good better and maybe to restrict the
development of everything that's
malevolent and evil within yourself and
in the broader world insofar as you're
able to do that and so I think that's an
expression of Love is that because when
you love something you care for it and
the proper attitude towards being I
think is care
and so so that's one element of God is
love God being
analogous in some way to being
um now we could look at God more
classically as the creator of being if
you assume being as good well it's not
much of a leap to assume the creator of
being is good and maybe you adopt an
attitude towards the creator of being
and that's also love and you open your
heart to existence and
maybe that's the most effective means of
having existence open its heart to you
so for example you know if you love
other people you want the best for them
you want the best and you deserve the
best in them if you love them and you
trust them courageously so you open
yourself up to them
I don't think it's unreasonable to
assume that that's how you elicit the
best from them the best that can be
elicited you're going to get hurt
sometimes and betrayed but that's going
to happen no matter what approach you
take I think that's the most effective
approach and that is perhaps the most
effective approach to existence per se
to approach it with love and courage and
and so that's how that looks to me
is it a feeling like loving a person yes
I think it is I think it is a feeling
like loving a person it's it's the
generalization of that care that you
would have for a child your child your
your brother your sister a family member
it's the generalization of that to the
broader domain of of existence to
broader domain of domains of existence
and I think that's a skill in some sense
right I mean if you're good at loving
and caring for your family but you can
expand that outward so that more people
are brought under that umbrella then
well assuming you can manage that it's
very difficult
it seems to me that that's laudable it
seems to me that we spontaneously admire
and would like to imitate people who are
capable of that and so you see that when
you have a job or you and you encounter
a boss who takes you under his or her
wing and helps develop you or you find a
teacher who's particularly inspiring or
you work for an entrepreneur who's
inspiring and who also opens doors for
you
um they're acting with love as far as
I'm concerned they want the best in them
to serve the best in you and that's very
very motivating for everyone and that's
the proper basis of our social
relationships not power for God's sake
so can love balance out the crushing
responsibility that's a sophisticated
question
I don't know the answer to that
love is warmer than responsibility love
is the is part of empathy and
agreeableness it's a different dimension
than responsibility which is more part
of conscientiousness and sort of a cold
virtue I don't know if it balances out
the crushing responsibility but I think
it's the emotional analog to the
crushing responsibility right so maybe
there's love and Duty and and they run
parallel in in if you're an ethical
person that's not all there is to ethics
but you know love and Duty they're
they're important and and maybe they're
better together than they would be as
independent
um entities at the end of God's creation
describing how order emerges from chaos
or being from potential there's this
strange line which is probably the most
important line that's ever been written
in our culture at the basis of our
culture and that is that men and women
are made in the image of God and what
does that mean well if God is that which
confronts potential with truth and
courage and makes what's good out of
potential that seems to indicate that we
have the same faculty like on a smaller
scale we're not omniscient but we're not
bloody well nothing our conscience is
integrally tied into the structure of
being in some manner we don't understand
and it certainly is the case that we
take what isn't and turn it is into what
is that's something man that's that's
quite the trick we've been able to
manage and so we're made in that image
and so what are we supposed to do well
that's what we're supposed to do we're
supposed to type our letters and make
our phrases and construct our sentences
and build our paragraphs and put our
chapters together and make our books and
communicate to people and straighten out
the damn culture and constrain the
malevolence and ignorance that besides
each of us and push nature back and
extend ourselves out into the unknown
and confront the potential that's there
in the illimitable quantities and make
the world better than it could be
otherwise to Move It Away From Hell
which and it can certainly become that
and toward heaven to the degree that we
can manage that and that is a good
enough goal that's the thing you need
something you know because your life is
tough It's hard you need something that
you know you need something to get out
of bed for and fight for and that's
something right to fight let's say
against hell and for heaven that's
something to fight for you want to be
convinced about this like read a little
bit about hell read the gulag
archipelago or read ordinary men or read
the rape of Nan King or read about what
happened in Nazi Germany during
Auschwitz and all the catastrophes of
the 20th century and see if you believe
in hell and see if you think well maybe
not having that happen anymore would be
a good idea and then think about maybe
that's something you could contribute to
then it wouldn't have to happen anymore
and that would be a good thing and God
only knows what great things we could
manage under such conditions we're
becoming incredibly technologically
powerful what would it be like if we
became equally wise well that would
really be something God only knows what
we could manage in the next 20 years or
the next hundred years you know we're
running at 40 percent most of us you
know because we're half in and half out
and it's not surprising because life is
difficult it's like well what if you
were 90 in or 95 in or or all in because
you're all in anyways right it's a it's
a life and death game no one gets out of
this everyone dies you might as well
commit yourself and you might as well
commit yourself to the highest good that
you can attain because why not it'll
imbue your life with meaning it's hard
the responsibility is there but all the
meanings in the responsibility and
that'll make your life better it'll make
your family's life better and it should
make your culture better
maybe make the world better it's like
that'll justify your damn miserable
existence at three o'clock in the
morning when you're wondering what the
hell you're doing here and that's a good
thing because there's going to be days
when you're aching and tired and sore
and there's people in your family that
are sick and you're cynical and bitter
and you need a reason to get up and you
think yeah well a little more heaven and
a little less hell maybe I can pull that
off today and tomorrow and next week and
that's where it's struggling forward for
so that's how it looks to me becoming
more articulate is definitely I would
say
that's the primary
array of weapons
so I mean physical prowess is something
and it's not nothing that physical
confidence that comes along with that as
well but
the same thing replicated at the level
of the ability to communicate and to
think that's
way broader field of of battle and
opportunity
so this is one thing that isn't taught
well especially to boys
it's more important to teach it to boys
I would say because they're more uh
skeptical of such of the educational
Enterprise in general generally speaking
partly because they're less obedient
partly because they're less agreeable
that's particularly true for
disagreeable boys
an agreeable boys get higher grades
independent of their IQ and their and
their academic achievement because
they're easier to deal with
so what do you tell disagreeable boys
there's nothing that makes you more
formidable than verbal competence than
being able to articulate be able to
think to Marshal your arguments right
some
Battlefield metaphor
to get everything in order
get all your information straight
no to Marshall your forces
and so I mean that's part of the reason
that rap
artists are so popular especially among
disaffected young men black and white
alike because they're unbelievably
articulate they have this incredible
verbal prowess it's unbelievably
attractive you know and it's associated
with genuine artistic and Redemptive
activity often focusing on
something that's approximately the voice
of the underclass let's say
but a powerful voice right and it's
interesting to see how many young white
guys identify with that there's so many
rules that are great but what do you
think is probably if if somebody was to
read those books and there's one rule
that you like this rule out of the 24
I've given you over these past few years
I you can absolutely not get this one
wrong which rule would that be
tell the truth or at least don't lie
because you can't tell the truth right
because who are you to tell the truth
that's a that's a mighty tall order man
but you can stop saying things that you
know are lies and that will change your
life
if you do that and it's crazy
well how can you adapt to reality when
you falsify it
you think well I'm just lying to other
people no you're not you can't just lie
to other people because what you say
becomes you especially if you practice
it because we build ourselves out of
words
and that can be lies in action too it's
like don't don't say things you know to
be false that's a that's a good start
man and it aligns yourself with the
truth and that like how can that be a
bad idea imagine that what is true
reflects reality which is sort of the
definition of true how can
failing to align yourself with reality
work how is that possibly going to work
well you say well I can you know if I
lie I get away with something it's like
no you don't
you know I I tell you I swear this is
true
in all of my clinical practice
I have never ever seen anyone ever get
away with anything even once
you think the chickens won't come home
to roost it's like
all that that means is you're too stupid
to see what your lies caused or too
blind or too self-deceptive you just
don't see it
and so you don't get away with anything
nothing it's terrifying to actually
understand that
it's terrifying
what if you can't get away with anything
ever you know well that's the judgmental
God fundamentally that's a very old idea
and it's an old idea for a reason and of
course you can't get away with anything
because imagine that you took a
flexible plastic comb you know when you
bent it backwards and you say well
I got away with that it's like well
what's going to happen when you let go
it's going to snap back and hit you in
the face and that's that's life man you
warp the structure of reality you think
you are someone who can warp the
structure of reality with your words and
get away with it really
no man that should that should terrify
you right to the core of your soul
you're not God my rule too is treat
yourself as if you're someone
responsible for helping and it's sort of
predicated on the idea that regardless
of your inadequacies and your
malevolence which you know I'm sure you
have many inadequacies and no shortage
of malevolence just like everyone else
regardless of that you have a moral
obligation so that would be a
responsibility to assume that despite
all evidence that there's actually
something of intrinsic worth about you
and that as a consequence your duty
bound to treat yourself like that is
true
and then it turns out that if you do
that
well then your life gets better
and and I don't mean happier exactly
although I would say it gets happier I
mean it gets richer and more meaningful
and deeper and and more worthwhile and
and you become more educated and you
become wiser and and and you treat
yourself with more respect and you're a
better model for other people and you're
a better father or a better sister or a
better mother whatever it happens to be
it's and you're less ridden by that
guilt that's that gnaws at you and shame
that's there otherwise saying you're not
what you could be you're not what you
could be and that's a hell of a voice to
get rid of and it's certainly not one
that's easy to ignore so that's a pretty
good
that that idea that there's something
Divine let's say that resides within you
of ultimate worth
um
even as a philosophical statement or a
psychological statement rather than a
metaphysical statement it seems to be a
precondition for establishing properly
harmonious relationships with yourself
and that's that's man that's worth
thinking about a lot you know that you
have because you think you couldn't
think that in some sense you just own
yourself you know because people do kind
of make that claim especially when
they're trying to justify for example
their right to Suicide that you know
it's it's your life it's your body your
yours to do what you will with and if
that was true well then it would seem to
me that life would be a lot more
straightforward because you would just
tell yourself things that you would
instantly obey and believe so first of
all you'd tell yourself all the things
that you were going to do and then you
just run off and do them which you don't
obviously because it's much more
difficult at that and then you'd also
say well enough of the guilt and the
shame and the negative emotion and the
disillusionment and the vengefulness and
all those things that make life hard
especially the self-recrimination it's
like what the hell do we need that for
and if we're our masters of Our Own
Destiny and owners of our own fate then
why can't we just command to ourselves
that that be dispensed with and like
that doesn't work I've never seen
anybody able to do that so I mean you
can fool yourself for very brief periods
of time into thinking that that might
work but
but it doesn't work and and that's
strange and this is one of the reasons I
love the psychoanalysts say because they
were really the people apart from the
religious types who figured out that
whatever you are
you're not a unitary Spirit that's under
your own dominion you know you're
something like a loose Unity of a
multiplicity of spirits many of which
are doing their own thing which you're
striving to bring into some form of
unity but even that Unity isn't
something that's under your control in
any real sense it's it's a Unity that
has its own nature that you have to
exist in relationship to and I would
also say that that's one of the things
that keeps people people's feet firmly
on the ground because otherwise you it's
easy to become egotistical and
narcissistic you know if you if you
think that you're the center of your own
being you know in some fundamental sense
then you're only what you're only
beholden to yourself you're sort of a
self-created creature perhaps you could
think about it that way but it doesn't
work like that it's like the ideal that
constitutes the unity that you might
become then sort of manifests itself is
something that you could strive toward
but aren't and it it also serves as a
judge it's the thing that keeps you up
at night saying you know there's some
things you're just not attending to and
you should get at it because life is
short and there's no shortage of trouble
that you might end up in and a wise
person would attend to the dictates of
his conscience and and lay out his
actions in the world according to what
he knows to be true and correct and
that is how people think and it isn't
obvious that we why we think that way
that this is part of the reason that it
seems to me so obvious that we have a
religious Instinct because I can't think
of what else you would possibly call
that other than a religious Instinct
thoughts on the drug epidemic
well I'm not sure there is an epidemic
any more than there always has been I
know that there is now a tilt towards
drugs in in the U.S in particular like
meth and and
um Fentanyl and the other opiates and
that's quite a catastrophe
um
a lot of that is occurring among people
who don't have
meaning in their lives I would say you
might think that's a facile answer but
it's not you know like here here's the
rat Literature Like It's if you take a
Rat Lab Rat typical lab rat is you know
genetically Brad uh
to be identical with many other lab
routes and he lives alone in a cage and
he he's got a pretty miserable route
life because rats are social animals and
they don't like to live in cages by
themselves and you can get a lab rat in
a cage addicted to cocaine in no time
flat and he'll he'll like press a lever
for cocaine reward pretty much to the ex
to the exclusion of all else including
sex and often including food but if you
take that same rat and you put them in a
rat family you know in a rat social
hierarchy in a rat environment and give
them something that rat rat like to do
so that he can be satisfied it's very
difficult to get him addicted to cocaine
and so I would say the reason that
people take psychomotor stimulants and
all the drugs of serious abuse are
psychomotor stimulants regardless of
what else they might be they activate
the dopaminergic system which is the
system that tracks reward and that that
is associated that's activated when you
pursue valuable goal-directed Behavior
if you don't have that if you don't have
a valid goal if you don't have and
there's no no real valid meaning in your
life you don't have a valid ambition
then you don't have any way of
activating that system and why the hell
wouldn't you take drugs it's like you
have to have something better to do to
not addict yourself you know so so I
would say that a huge part of the
current epidemic in in the U.S in
particular is is Manifest among broken
men who have no real place in society
and providing them with money isn't
going to help that they need a
productive and meaningful existence and
which is the Paramount the Paramount
goal should be the Paramount goal of
social of social policy for example we
it isn't the alleviation of poverty
that's really the issue because people
in the west aren't poor there might be a
bit of a distribution problem but we're
not poor what we have is a
so uh what would you say a
we have a problem of meaningful
engagement and that's what has to be
addressed and that's why I do the work
that I'm doing there's an entire what
literature psychoanalytic literature on
the dangers of over compassion hyper
protectiveness helicopter parenting all
of that when you have children you have
to encourage them you have to encourage
them to take risks because they have to
grow up and take their place in the
world you can't protect them too much
because if you do you destroy them
that's the motif of Hansel and Gretel
right two kids lost in the woods
they find the gingerbread house that's a
little bit too good to be true right
it's not only shelter when you need it
but it's candy what lives inside the
house that's too good to be true the
witch that devours you
right that's excess compassion so you
don't want your mother to do everything
for you that's for sure there's a rule
if you're dealing with the elderly and
like Extended Care Homes
don't do anything for your clients that
they can do themselves
because you undermine their autonomy and
so there's a certain amount of harshness
that goes along with that just as there
is if you're a good mother because you
have to separate yourself from your
child and allow them to make hurtful
mistakes right I mean it's very
difficult if you're a compassionate
person to stand back far enough to let
your children take necessary risks
but one thing I'm not getting there's a
big difference between letting people do
something for themselves and saying men
should be dangerous by dangerous that
implies I should be ready to threaten
someone to hurt somebody no you should
be capable of it
but that doesn't mean you should use it
there's nothing to you otherwise like if
you're not a formidable Force there's
not there's no morality in your
self-control if you're incapable of
violence not being violent isn't a
virtue people who teach martial arts
know this full well right if you learn a
martial art you learn to be dangerous
but simultaneously you learn to control
it both of those come together and the
combination of that capacity for danger
and the capacity for control is what
brings about the virtue otherwise you
confuse weakness with with moral virtue
I'm harmless therefore I'm good it's
like no that isn't how it works that
isn't how it works at all if you're
harmless you're just weak and if you're
weak you're not going to be good you
can't be because it takes strength to be
good it's very difficult to be good your
perceptual structures are determined by
the goals that you have at hand I mean
some of that's that's not completely
true because your perceptual systems
also have limitations right there's
things you can't see or hear even if you
need to so there are limitations built
in but within that set of limitations
you're still trying to tune your
perceptions to your motivated goals and
that's also very useful to think about
when you're trying to understand
artificial intelligence because for
human beings without goals there's no
perception because there's no filtering
mechanism that you can use to determine
the level of resolution at which you
perceive anyway so there's the there's a
thing made of smaller things which are
made out of smaller things and it's so
it's kind of my iconic representation of
the complexity of the world and then you
could think well what is this how can
you see this object and I think if you
just look at it you can detect it's like
a [ __ ] cube you know those cubes that
that are line drawings that you can see
the front of and then it'll flip to the
back have you seen those so this is kind
of neck or cube like or at least it is
for me in that when I look at it
my perceptions play around with it
sometimes I focus on the kind of
cross-like shape in the middle and
sometimes I can see these other lines
and then sometimes I'll focus on that
square and sometimes I can see the
little dots there maybe one dot and my
perceptions are going like this trying
to fit a pattern to it and I you can
kind of detect that when you're watching
it and so I would say well you have the
options of perceiving this in its full
complexity or you can simplify it
essentially there's lots of ways you can
simplify it but some of them are laid
out there so you take the comp complex
thing you make a low resolution
representation of it so that's it's
rough that's the rough area that all
those dots occupy that's the rough area
broken down to its four most fundamental
quadrants that might be how you would
look at it if if this was a map of an
orchard and you were trying to walk from
south to North that would be a useful
representation this combines this and
this that's the
that's the highest level of resolution
that you can perceive this object at
that's lower resolution than the object
itself
so the first issue is how should you
look at things well that's a problem
that intelligence has to solve so that's
one of the problems that intelligence
goes after and then I think what happens
is we have the thing in itself and then
we simplify it with a perception
and that's like an iconic representation
and then we we nail the iconic
representation with a word and that's
how we compress the world's complexity
into something that we can manage we
take the complex thing make it into an
icon and represent the icon with a word
and then when I throw you the word so to
speak you decompose it into the icon and
then decompose it even further into the
thing if you can't if you know the icon
and you know the thing and so then we
can use shorthand right because you have
representational structures and so do I
and I'm just tossing you markers about
your representational structures and you
can unfold them that's what you do when
you're reading a novel
because the novel comes alive in your
imagination in your own idiosyncratic
way and it wouldn't if you didn't
understand the references of the novel
right the novelist has to assume that
your basic perceptual structures and
your intuitions and your instincts are
basically the same as his or hers
because otherwise they have to assume
that because otherwise they would be
lost in an infinite regressive
explanation
so and it's problematic often for
example if you start reading Victorian
novels you may find that it takes a
while to get into them because the
presuppositions the expectations are
slightly different and so is the
language you have to update the
representations the notion that our
morality is linked to our desire to
survive is I'm perfectly fine with that
the devil's in the details to some
degree
I mean one of the
fields of endeavor that I've been
particularly struck by is uh
the work of people like Franz DeWall
and friends to wall has written a series
and also Jacques penkseb hey I'll tell
you something cool about rats some of
you I'd like to do that
some of you have probably heard this
before but this affective neuroscientist
named Jacques panksab he studied rats
for a long time and he's very
sophisticated researcher and I think he
was one of the greatest neuroscientists
who lived in the last 50 years sorry I
don't think there's really any question
of that he might have been one of the
top three
might have been
he'd be in the top three be a tight race
up at the top three
he did this great experiment it was so
smart
so
juvenile robs like to play
and they like to wrestle they like to
engage in rough and tumble play and you
might say well how do you know a rat
likes to do something it's like or
you're anthropomorphizing and the first
thing I would say to that is you should
anthropomorphize unless there's evidence
to the contrary because we share a
biological platform with rats and
they're a lot like us and a rat is a lot
more like you than your stupid model of
a human being is like a human being
so you try building a rat
it's hard
so anyways you can tell rats want to
play because if you put them in a little
Arena where they can Rough and Tumble
play and wrestle and then you bring them
there the next time and you make them
work to open the door to play they'll
work and so that's how we know you like
something you'll work for it you know so
you can apply that to rats and they'll
work hard for it and rats deprived of
play their prefrontal cortexes don't
mature and they they're kind of
hyperactive which might tell us
something about boys in school but we
won't go into that
if you take a rat
of the same age as another rat and you
put them in a play area
but the other route has a 10 weight
advantage
the big rat will pin the little rat and
they actually pin each other pretty much
like dogs do when they're wrestling
while they don't pin quite as much but
humans certainly do it and pin means
dominate dominance or that's one
interpretation
you only make that interpretation if you
think that the hierarchies that rats
live in are dominance hierarchies
predicated on the expression of power
and we all kind of think that because we
use the term dominance hierarchy but you
know that's a political term as well as
a scientific term and it's predicated on
the notion that the fundamental basis of
hierarchical structure among mammals and
other complex organisms is power and
that's wrong
it's not just wrong it's it's
corrosively wrong
it's misleadingly wrong it's like it's
seriously and not acceptably wrong
anyways you pair the rats once and you
think hey big rat wins over little rat
establishes dominance That's the basis
of the relationship
but the thing about rats is like people
they don't just play once because they
live in social groups that are
reciprocal they play repeatedly and
Banks up being a very smart researcher
realized this so he paired rats
to play the same routes over multiple
occasions
and the first thing he observed was the
second time the rats got together the
little rat had to invite the big rat to
play
you know when rats do the same sort of
thing that dogs do when they want to
play and and that that play behavior is
so cross-species common that all of you
know when your dog wants to play you
know you can you can take your dog and
whack him like that if you do it right
and he goes and tries to bite you but
not really right he plays in his Tails
wagging and and when dogs are playing it
kind of looks like dominance Behavior
like it does among boys because boys
really like to rough and humble play by
the way although girls like it too but
not as much
you can distinguish the play behavior
from aggression and if you can't that
means you never had any friends I mean
no I mean that that's that I mean that
that's what it means it means that's
what it means because part of being able
to have friends is be to be able to
identify aggression versus play and and
part of playing is to pretend to be
aggressive quite aggressively but still
be playing right there's a tremendous
social skill in that anyways
the little rat has to ask the big rat to
play which I imagine is somewhat you
know humiliating for the little rat but
he's the little rat so tough luck for
him and the big rat contained to play
and then they play and then you can
observe how they play over repeated
boats
if the big rat doesn't let the little
rat win at least 30 percent of the time
even though he could win 100 of the time
the little rat will no longer invite him
to play and you think
yeah it's like no not yeah
like the emergence of morality in rats
through play that's a big Discovery man
that's a big Discovery and that's
there's that reciprocity eh that that
exists within the rat hierarchy and
stable hierarchies in complex mammals
are not predicated on power
so friends the wall has shown quite
clearly that you know that so chimps
have a pretty rough hierarchy and it's
pretty male dominated now barnables are
quite different we won't talk about them
because it's not germane to this
particular point but you might think you
know
the biggest chimpanzee with the biggest
teeth
he's the Tyrant he's the winner
and that happens sometimes there are
tyrannical chimpanzee societies but what
DeWalt has shown quite clearly is that
I don't care how big and tough you are
if you don't play fair
two guys 90 your size can get together
one day when you're not feeling so well
and tear you into bits
and that's exactly what happens Among
The Chimps
so tyranny you know that can be a route
to dominance it can even be a route to
sexual access because it is the case
among chimpanzees that males who are
higher in the power hierarchy are more
likely to farther Offspring not because
the female chimps choose them because
female chimps aren't choosy unlike human
females it's a profound difference
between the two species but because the
big that more uh superordinate male
chimps chase the soup subordinates away
so but the wall is shown quite clearly
that
the males who managed to occupy
positions of authority
and competence longest in chimpanzee
hierarchies are intensely reciprocal
with the other males more so than the
other chimps in the hierarchy they do a
lot of mutual grooming and are
preferentially attentive to the females
and their infants
and so even among chimps and chimps can
be damn brutal right Jane Goodall
discovered I think it was 1975 another
landmark in in late 20th century
scientists at science that
and this was a real blow to to the
social
constructionist utopians
juvenile chimps Patrol the borders of
their territory and if they come across
chimps from other troops and outnumber
them they will tear them into bits and
chimps are unbelievably strong and it's
unbelievably brutal and so good all
basically discovered that chimps have
the human equip or the the equivalent of
human tribal Warfare
and that's quite frightening if you're
sensible because you know you might be
the kind of optimist who thinks that
human conflict is caused by capitalism
or some bloody Daft notion like that and
that wouldn't that be lovely because
then it would be you could just get rid
of it by getting rid of capitalism which
you wouldn't be able to do anyways but
you know what I mean it's but if it's I
mean we split from chimps about seven
million years ago and
if the problem of Intergroup aggression
is that deep
it's a terrible problem because people
think that the purpose of memory is to
remember the past and that's not the
purpose of memory the purpose of memory
is to extract out from the past lessons
to structure the future and that's the
purpose of personal memory and so you're
done with a memory when you've extracted
out the information that you can use to
guide yourself properly in the future so
if you have a traumatic memory for
example that's really obsessing you if
you analyze that memory to the point
where you figured out how you put
yourself at risk and you can determine
how you might avoid that in the future
then the emotion associated with that
goes away so memories has a very
pragmatic function and cultural memory
is the same thing is that we need to
extract out stories from our past that
structure our future and we need that
because
well first of all if you don't have a
purpose let's say it isn't that your
life becomes neutral in a meaningless
sense it's that your life becomes
characterized by unbearable suffering
because the Baseline condition of life
is something like unbearable suffering
and what you have to set against that is
a noble and worthwhile purpose and
hopefully hopefully your determination
of that purpose is buttressed to some
degree by the wisdom of the past because
you can't conjure something like that up
on your own and if you provide people
with nobility of purpose then they can
tolerate the suffering of existence
without becoming entirely corrupted by
it and cultures that don't do that it
isn't even so much that they die it's
that cultures that don't do that are
dead they're done they don't have a
story anymore they don't have a call to
Adventure and then well then everyone
suffers stupidly as a consequence it's a
very bad thing so Churchill made the
same observation that many of the Great
psychologists and and philosophers made
in the early of the 20th century it's
like
bring the story forward and and
propagate it and make it the most noble
possible story and then you motivate
people to do to transcend themselves
which they need to do so yes he's
exactly right in his diagnosis the goal
of life is to live a life which in
retrospect we are glad that we lived
it's important to give ourselves
perspective
to develop that metacognizance to step
away from the Urgent to step away from
the phenomenological day-to-day
existence because the present self is a
petulant child it's lazy and it wants
the path of least resistance and that
glass of wine and that new movie on
Netflix and the couch looks really
comfortable
very rarely does it yeah well that's the
danger with impulsive happiness is that
it does have that present bound quality
and in retrospect
that can lead to a life that's not well
lived
generally that yes yes yes
life
definitely places philosophical demands
on you whether you want to or not and so
it is just useful to step back I mean
that's likely why
the trade openness evolved that's the
creativity Dimension that's the
dimension that that allows people to
engage in philosophical discourse and to
think laterally and it it does allow you
to step back and look at things on a
broader scale and to generate creative
Alternatives the problem with examining
your assumptions is it's very
disquieting
you know because
you want things to act the way you
predict and desire them to act
and you work within a set of axioms and
you act them out in order to maintain
that predictability
that desirable predictability
if you mess around the more fundamental
the Axiom that you question the more
uncertainty you release
and some of that can be positive but a
plenty of it can be anxiety provoking I
mean just imagine that you're in a
relationship and you know it's it's
maybe a year into it you haven't
formalized and finalized it but then one
day you allow yourself to ask the
question is this the relationship I want
to be in well that's a fundamental
question but just imagine now you're
destabilizing your entire future
you're destabilizing your present you're
destabilizing your past because while
engaging in the relationship you're
acting out the assumption that it's the
proper relationship but now you question
that that means the story you told
yourself about what was happening well
it happened even though it's already
happened was wrong and something else
had happened and then you have to think
through what actually happened so it's
unbelievably demanding and the more
axiomatic the Assumption the more
certainty is cast into into Troublesome
chaos now you could say yeah but the
alternative is worse
and I believe that often that's true but
but the thing about the alternative is
that you can always forestall it right
that question tomorrow you bet you bet
and it's a very powerful Temptation and
no wonder
you know do you want to dig up the body
now or do you want to wait a month it's
like well it'll be more rotten in a
month but
but it's not a month it's not now right
it's not now
and so I I understand why people don't
want to delve into things even if their
emotions indicate that they should I
mean I would see this all the time if
you're trying to settle an important
issue with your partner let's say
that can be a tremendously Troublesome
excavation process
and there's no shortage of pain but
if you sort it out then maybe things can
be better doesn't mean it's easy or or
or uh or Pleasant quite the contrary
it's like surgery it's not it's like
surgery to remove something you know
that shouldn't be there it's necessary
but man it's still surgery so then you
could imagine
I have this Cottage
in Northern Ontario and
we're fortunate
uh it's dark there and so you can go
down to the dock at night and in the
clear sky you can see the vast array of
the infinite heavens arrayed above you
you know and it's something that people
who live in cities really don't get to
experience anymore they don't experience
the sunset which we also go out on our
boat and watch pretty much every day
and that puts you in in touch with what
inspires awe
now when that's not a propositional
experience that's a pre-propositional
experience and it's it's a deep
biological experience it's in it's
embedded in the prey response to a
predator in part you know because if you
if you feel awe sometimes you can feel
that with music a lot of people are high
in openness to experience will feel that
quite frequently under the effect of
aesthetic experiences interestingly
enough their hair stands on in that's
pilo erection that's what a cat does
when it's frightened by a dog like the
little boy at the beginning of the story
you know the cat puffs up to look big to
be like medic hat so that it can contend
with it can contend with dogs or at
least it can look like it might and so
when when it sees a dog the sight of the
dog calls the best fourth out of the cat
well that's what happens when you look
at the night sky
you know
he calls to you
right Dr Dawkins sent me a paper last
week in preparation for a discussion
that we're going to have tomorrow and it
was a very interesting paper and I think
I read it about 25 years ago and he said
any functioning animal has to be a
microcosm a model of the environment
within within which it finds itself
well
that's true of us
and so when you look at the night sky
and
that
sense of awe grips you and calls
something out of you right to respond to
your encounter with the infant and even
your encounter with mortality you're
encounter with finitude and limitation
all of that in relationship to the
infinite
that sense of awe is also the calling
forth of something out of you that can
respond to the challenge of that
infinite
well that's the microcosm within no it's
a reflection of the structure of the
cosmos itself
that's the Divine ideal
and we either imitate that or we fail to
imitate that or we pursue the opposite
path
those are the options you know and it's
given our technological power and our
capacity for wholesale atrocity it's
time we woke up and realized it
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
some powerful habits to start every day
with check the video right there next to
me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there but if
there's something inside of you that is
restless for that next level we're gonna
have to start measuring if you don't
measure it you can't improve it you know
if you ever try to lose weight or gain
you've noticed apparently this is a
weightlifting